We are now entering the modeling phase.
Let's switch back to the iPython Notebook.
To recall briefly we had chosen person 1 as B and person 2 as F.
And we are going to classify them according to their location patterns.
We did a final sanity check to ensure that the features chosen actually seem to
have discriminating power.
At this point let's run this piece of code.
What it does is, it fills an array named classification_events with
the events of person B and person F.
We are now going to split the data in a training set and a test set.
In this case we are going to use 60% of the data on training, and 40% on test.
Let's go ahead and do that first.
At this point, we have split the data into training and test sets.
We are using a large portion of the data for
testing, as we will be illustrating several validation matrix on the test data.
Just as a sanity check.
We want to plot our features within our training data.
Once you have run the above code, you should get histograms for
the distribution of different distances at a certain time for each person.
Remember we wanted to make three different classifiers.
To do so we have now split our data set.
Into the training and the test set.
We also asked a quick question.
Are the features different enough in the training data set?
We validated that again by looking at the histogram of the different features.
So now we are ready to run the three classification models.
Let's get back to the iPython notebook again.
In this part of the code, we are setting up the three models for
our classification problems.
We are using the sklearns logistic
regression support vector classifier and the random forest classifier.
This method here simply returns the model that we want to train.
So now let's run this code.
After you're done with defining the three models, let's simply build the models.
It's as simple as this one line of code.
Let's run it.
And there you have it.
We have the models built.
In the following videos we will use some of Sklearn's built in
model alidation metrics to give us the performance of these models.
Before that, let us define some of the quantities we might want to
look at,when evaluating the performance of classifiers